[Music]
if i
injure you the injury persists even
after i actually commit the act
if i stab you you may suffer
complications long after that
initial actual stabbing that's the case
with african-americans they're people
well within the living
memory of this country they're still
suffering from the after effects
what do we want revelation
[Music]
reparations are meant to redress
or compensate for
a really egregious injustice
it can be compensation in terms of
money there also needs to be
a moral reckoning the historical
injustice has never been
addressed ending an injustice is not the
same thing as making up for its enduring
effect
we need to have that controversial
conversation ongoing
so that we can begin to do something
about it
repair is happening because we said yes
a world shocked beyond belief sees the
barbaric work of the dying nazi beast
i'm originally from germany and i grew
up there
the holocaust was discussed in every
single school subject
and i felt horrible about my history and
ashamed of it the ragged prettiest
handful
who survived but then one day i met
nietzsche langer a survivor of five
concentration camps and a death march in
his youth
after he passed away i learned from his
widow that
he had received a reparations pension
since the 1970s
first from the west german government
then from the government of reunited
germany
it was a small pension it measured no
way up to the
losses he had as a youngster and there
is no money amount that could possibly
represent those losses
when i came to the united states i was
drawn to that topic of reparations from
my experience with mirchu
the procedure that i used to estimate
reparations
i took census information about the
enslaved population in each year from
1776
to 1860 i'm adding up all the hours
multiplying it with the wages customary
at the time
and then adding a conservative three
percent interest
i arrive at a outstanding debt of 20.3
trillion dollars in 2021
we can see by the polls that support for
reparations
is over 70 among black americans
a small but growing number of white
americans
also believe that reparations are due to
african americans and i think that's an
important distinction
it's not a handout it's a debt
the advocates for reparations explain
in a heartbreaking way you know the
systemic
ways in which blacks and black families
have been prevented and held back from
building up the kind of generational
wealth that many
white americans can expect i think
reparations
ask us to imagine what america could be
like
without that kind of discrimination as
we begin to repair
the legacy of that discrimination like
what could america
look like
as an elected alderman here i serve my
most immediate neighborhood which is the
fifth ward the historically black
community in evanston we are a small
city we're just north of chicago
aesthetically beautiful mature trees you
know the home of northwestern
university majority white and majority
affluent
the black community right now is less
than 17
we had been in the mid 20 before
um as as early as 2010 so there have
been an exodus in the black community
i saw that there were historic and
intentional systemic barriers between
black evanston enjoying the same
livability as the rest of evanston and
we were going along
still celebrating our diversity and
inclusion and and that being a brand
but still carrying year after year the
ratio separation
household income gap the wealth gap the
education gap and so on
i didn't have the thought to localize
reparations
until february of 2019 and it was in
that moment
that i immediately sent out the initial
email
to make the recommendation to the equity
empowerment commission
to begin the road to repair in the city
of evanston
the local governments also have their
own specific
egregious acts against the black
community that are verifiable
and documented and have measurable harms
so in my role as a local elected i
thought
that i might lead locally you know the
front line is where your feet are
the first real grassroots movement for
reparations
that was led by a woman named cali house
it was in the 1890s and
was almost a two-decade long struggle
for her and she
made a claim to the federal government
for pensions
she used the mail to to communicate
with washington and then also to
encourage people to join the movement
you know at one point she had almost 300
000 people
had signed up were paying dues and
the government in response accused her
of using the mail for fraud
she was actually convicted by an
all-white jury
and spent a year in prison
reparations for slavery have been paid
repeatedly in history
but to the wrong side to the slave
owners rather than the
enslaved the french government sent a
fleet to haiti to demand
reparations for the abolition of slavery
there similarly the british government
paid reparations to the enslavers in
in great britain in the united states
two reparations were paid to slave
owners
in washington dc when slavery was
abolished there in 1863
the recipients were white it was
considered normal and it's interesting
that
the the program becomes controversial
when the recipients are black
staff recommend city council adoption of
resolution 126
r19 establishing the city of evanson
reparation fund and creating a revenue
source for the fund
so in 2019 we passed resolution 126
r19 which restricted the first 10
million dollars of cannabis sales tax to
fund reparations programming
we selected that as a city as our
funding mechanism because
71 percent of the marijuana arrests were
in the black community and if you
remember i said we're only
less than 17 percent of the population
so certainly over policing
is an issue and was an issue in fact
then so
what more appropriate way than to use
that tax revenue for repair
eligibility is black residents that
lived here between 1919 and 1969
and their direct descendants and they
will receive
if selected a 25 000 direct benefit that
can be used for
housing to build wealth they can use it
to purchase a home
it can be used to make any type of home
improvements but it has to be used to
build wealth through home equity
evanston passed this program and now it
is the first city
in america to begin a program of
reparations
that is a pretty momentous occasion
it's gotten a lot of attention
and you know it is showing a way that
a city can repair harm done to
its citizens now the program initially
this four hundred thousand dollars um
that will be
given out in grants of up to twenty five
thousand dollars
will go to probably about 16 families
i think the city council is aware that
it's a small
modest program and it's a first step
i am confident that my four parents and
the many elders who raised me and paved
the way for me
are rejoicing because this is a move
forward for the nation and the world
reparations when you hear the term and
as someone who's lived
18 generations in one parish
and a southern state this is not
reparations
a vote in support of reparations program
is a sign that my family is welcome here
it is a sign that evanston cares
about families that look like mine it is
an act of equity
when one is building a house one does
not
build a kitchen and then say we will add
other rooms as we figure out what kind
of home
we're going to build it's just bad
public policy
and it blatantly leaves an impression
that black people are not entitled to
the same levels of concern
and care as other city programs and
projects
reparations is a sensitive you know very
controversial topic that
gets at trauma that the black community
has suffered and a grant of 25 thousand
dollars
doesn't to many people seem to even
begin
to really repair that harm or
acknowledge
the damage there is concern that
you know calling this reparations takes
away
from this very big idea that the
us federal government needs to be
responsible
for a very big program that would
benefit all eligible black americans
i had a colleague when i first began to
discuss this in 2019
recommend let's call it anything other
than reparations
just to avoid the controversy that made
it very clear we needed to call it what
it is
but everyone in this process is going to
be uncomfortable
the black community we are renaming our
injury and that's uncomfortable
the white community they're dealing with
their legacy of racism
you know if our ancestors were enslaved
you know their ancestors were enslavers
and so those are
uncomfortable conversations that we're
having together as a community
and it's really been a very productive
experience over the last couple of years
i've been appointed to serve on the
reparations committee so i will be
looking at
how do we increase this initial 10
million
to you know 100 million in the next few
years
and how do we expand the work from a
10-year goal
to in perpetuity because it will take
that long for us to get
to bridging our racial divide in
evanston
i've been also appointed to the national
african-american reparations commission
and i will serve along my colleagues
there supporting
other localities and lending my voice
and
advocacy to advance hr 40 as well
h.r 40 is a resolution
to study reparations
to look at what they might mean in
america what they might cost
how they might be structured it's a way
to answer some of the important
and also sort of logistical questions
about reparations
who would be eligible you know what
would a program look like
and how would we pay for it
reparations means making up for things
that happened in the past
we should study reparations and make
making what they should be
what they should do there's certain
things we already know
and i support that study let's see where
it takes us
we have a president who has said he
supports the study of reparations
the country has been awakened and
punched in the face
with our racism that we experience
far too often through social streaming
and
other ways of public lynchings of black
people
we are entering an era of repair
the roman catholic church just made a
commitment to
100 million dollars for reparations
there have been universities
that have done the same corporations are
beginning to set aside dollars
specifically not just for
all marginalized communities but the
black community
localities are doing the same in
advancing reparations
in germany 20 years after the
reparations program the young
generations
asked the older generations where were
you what did you do
what happened in our city in our town we
have a situation where we have
street names memorials and
military bases still named for southern
generals
for the traders in this country but not
enough for the people that actually
helped abolish slavery and that
put us on the right track of history so
i think there's a lot that education can
do and
a bottom-up process would be fantastic
we're all learning and growing together
we all aspire to
repair the community and we're learning
from
our history but we have to take a first
step and we've taken our first step in
evanston
you